the most intrinsically rewarding way i
could probably live my life was to
resist my labels elon musk or kanye west
i don't love all of their ideas but the
thing i loved and
admired most about those individuals was
they didn't let their past or a label
or anything define define them and that
inspires me i think that's a free way to
live i think everybody
the vast majority 99 of people don't
live freely they live
confined by words that you know their
mum or dad or themselves have given them
first off mate i need to say thank you
for dinner because the last time that we
were together we were overlooking
downtown dubai and you invited me and a
buddy out for a really wonderful evening
dinner
but then as you left i was in the toilet
so i haven't actually got to say goodbye
so
thanks for dinnermate and also welcome
in the show
thanks for having me i i left abruptly
because i had a flight to catch that
night and my suitcases were actually
downstairs so
when my pa grabbed me and said you know
you've got to go now i just i'd quickly
scrambled and uh
exited the building but yeah thank you
it's good to get to meet you and catch
up with you in such and i'm excited to
be in your podcast today
yeah me too man so why did you write a
book you've got a lot of stuff
online already like why do you need a
book as an outlet
this is a couple of you make a really
good point um we live in an era of
you know instantaneous feedback and um
i'm a i'm a connected from birth um i'm
part of the connected from birth
generation where i've had
you know some form of online connection
for my whole life and things have got
even more
um superficial and ephemeral um as i've
as i've got older so you're right i've
got millions of followers online
if i've got a message to communicate why
don't i just do an instagram story or
something
which gives me that sort of instant
feedback and i think in fact
that was um paradoxically why i needed
to write the book because of the way
that the world
was is heading and the the lack of
meaning and
how shallow um uh and
surface level things are getting and for
me the book the book is the antithesis
of that is depth it's meaning it's
something you
you spend two years doing and then once
you're done you still have another
year's wait until
it's published and um it was a chance to
really there's so many things with books
that i came to learn that you don't get
with social media as well
one of the real big things which i think
changes the way you create your ideas
is you because you don't get instant
feedback or
pretty much no not a lot of feedback at
all there's no comments section
you write with a certain level of
freedom which is quite rare these days
so
i got to go deeper than i've ever gone
before i know that if i write a page
um it's not going to be discussed
instantaneously and i think that allows
thoughts and ideas to connect in a
different way so just
for me it was a bit of an experiment to
be honest something i put off for a long
time
but um just to conclude that point there
was one day where i looked at my diary
from when i was 18 years old and in the
front page of it i basically written i
wanted to be a happy sexy millionaire
and i read that when i was 26 and i you
know built this massive business and i
was traveling from one country to
another
and that was the moment where i thought
i wanted to write the book because
it dawned on me how dumb i was to aim
for that and how many other people are
an interesting point around the instant
feedback i had seth godin on the show
and he said that about a decade or a
decade and a half ago he removed
comments from his blog
remembering he's one of the biggest
bloggers on the planet and people say
you can't remove comments from your blog
it's a blog you're not allowed to do
that and he was like well
i know if i leave comments on i'll just
add an extra caveat here
and a little bit of a justification
there because you're writing to preempt
what people are going to say back
and i think yeah the um the low-tech
solution of just
words on a piece of paper is uh is good
the title as well happy sexy millionaire
we tempted to call it just
be consistent for a really long time no
so
the the title as i say comes from when i
was 18 years old so i'm an 18 year old
kid i arrive in manchester
and um i decided i'm going to drop out
of university i know what i want from my
life i've it's for me
it's pretty non-negotiable that i'm
going to become
one way or the other a very successful
multi-millionaire at a very young age
that was
it was all weight from the age of 14 i
was i got to the point of 1415
where i was so convinced that that was
gonna happen um
with no evidence and no understanding of
the the future world that i would face
but i was so convinced
so i arrived in manchester 18 years old
realized that this degree wasn't going
to give me what i needed to to get to
where i needed to go
and uh dropped out and then wrote in the
first page of that diary which i posted
on facebook if anyone wants to check it
out i just wrote
four four goals that i have performed
25. a range rover sport was going to be
my first car
um i was going to make a million pounds
before i was 25 i was going to work on
my body because i was super skinny
um and i was going to have a long-term
relationship with a girl four very
simple life goals i wanted to be uh
sexy and rich because i thought that
would make me happy and that's that's
where the
the book starts where does that self
belief come from
it's a great question and i think i'm
always super scared
of um indulging in like high hindsight
[ __ ] where you
you look back and you say oh this this
and this and this is why i am the way i
am
i think largely like seventy percent of
the time eighty percent of the time we
don't know
but if i was was to hypothesize
logically where belief
comes from generally um other beliefs
that i have
the answer is clearly evidence right
some form of evidence that you have and
and what you sort of derive from that
evidence and the example that i give and
i think i give this example in my book
as well
as i talk about if i was to try and make
you believe that i was
allah or jesus christ right now and i
held your your mother hostage at
gunpoint and told you to
take that belief on the only way i'm
going to believe
the only way i'm going to release your
mother from gunpoint is if you start to
believe that i'm jesus christ right
you you couldn't believe it you couldn't
genuinely believe it even if everything
was on the line
and so i used to think about that and so
okay well if that's if we can't
if we don't actually choose our beliefs
we choose our faith
right we can have faith in something or
somebody but we don't actually choose
our belief where are they coming from
that in that same analogy if i take this
bottle here full of water and i turn it
into wine
and then i start levitating your belief
stop might start to change as it relates
to me being
a deity or something and so you take
that back and you say okay so far if our
beliefs are based on some kind of
evidence we have and what we derive from
that
maybe our self-belief is too maybe you
know maybe we're
compounding a set of personal case
studies in our life that are telling us
that we are capable of something or that
we're not
and it tends to be the case that from
the things that i've read anyway that
the
positive case studies upwards are slower
so i can i do one thing
i speak on stage in front of 10 people
i'm like okay and then i can do 15 the
next day
but when it compounds downwards against
you when your self-belief or any belief
compounds downwards it's rapid
you go on stage and speak in front of 10
people they heckle you you forget your
words
you never go trying to get back to that
stage again
is it's tough and so i think from a very
young age because of
my parents absence they weren't around
when i was when i was younger and i was
growing i was basically raising myself
from
about 10 years old i i learnt this very
important connections the
connection that i hope my kids one day
have which is if i'm going to get
something whether it's dinner money or
the nice pair of shoes that i want
because i'm broke and all the other kids
have them
it's going to come from my own actions
and behavior and you learn that at 10
years old that if if you're going to get
shoes or football you know whatever
lunch
it's going to come from something you do
so that sense of independence
created a creator helped me create a
bunch of case studies for myself
and some social factors i think are what
gave me my sense of self belief
that would be my that would be my guess
i think that you're right and it
highlights something i've been thinking
about for a long time
we presume in 2021 because people
conflate the words confidence with
extroversion and being charismatic and
outgoing all of these words move in the
same sort of
fields but confidence isn't the same
confidence isn't given it's earned
naval ravicant has this quote where he
says self-esteem is the reputation you
have with yourself
you'll always know and a lot of the time
i think people
want the self-belief the outcome the i
can achieve anything mentality
when they have zero evidence that it's
going to actually happen
and this is where small winds come in
right
clean your room make your bed do the
little things and build up and that's
what you've said the progressive
overload
yeah and this is one of the this is why
i've always been i've always had this
allergic reaction
to this idea of like pure play
visualization
because it's it's such a dumb thing to
me this idea that
there's almost this emerging culture
where people will get up in the morning
they'll repeat these three affirmations
and it's kind of like my analogy of just
saying that you think i'm jesus because
your mom's gonna die like they'll look
in the mirror and say i
am strong i am powerful i am whatever
and then they'll they'll write on their
little list of visualizations that i'm
gonna be a millionaire
and like but they haven't built any
personal case studies they don't
actually believe at all what they're
saying it's just a bunch of nonsense
like in their own self-esteem valleys
just a bunch of like wishy-washy
the difference is at 18 years old i
believed i was capable and i used to say
to people at the time i was like
if you tell me that i have to go to
mars this week my brain defaults to like
find out how to make it happen not it's
not possible or
why won't it happen and for some i had
that because of a set of case studies
that proceeded that moment
and some people don't and this is why
like yeah i'm quite against the whole
secret um lifestyle that some people
live where it's it's all about
visualization and
and not enough about you know small
compounding efforts
in the right direction yeah we're in the
same page there
what does the things that invalidated
you when you were younger are the things
which will validate you when you're
older mean
yeah so i think the quote from the book
is the things that invalidated you when
you're younger will be the
things you seek validation from when
you're older and you can you could that
can be anything right so for me
i was imagine this i come from africa as
a two-year-old kid
and you put me in an area where
everybody is richer than me
everybody is has a different hair hair
color than me everybody has a different
skin color than me
you put me into a street where
everyone's house is perfect
right perfect like out of a movie and
mine has
six foot grass and fridges and tvs in
the in the front garden back garden
the front window of my house is smashed
so this is already a kid that has some
kind of insecurity at that age as well
and so i was invalidated by that i was
invalidated because the things that made
me
feel invalid or insecure were like money
and the fact that i could never have a
girlfriend or have a girlfriend come
over to my house because it was a
[ __ ] hole and so as i got older you get
to 18 you're like i'm gonna try and fill
that hole
and so the things that had invalidated
me when i was a kid which was like
female attention or money or whatever it
was became the things that were most
valuable to me in my perception to to
um to seek and to chase when i was older
and you see this
no matter who you speak to whether it's
your dad invalidated you by
you know giving you the impression that
you could never be like him or you
weren't good enough
and then you know most of my billionaire
friends i think two of my billionaire
friends
and i haven't got that many of them uh
both of them have almost an identical
story
where their dad invalidated them when
they were younger these are two
billionaires you would know
and they spent their than you know their
early years
ruthlessly chasing that validation from
somewhere
isn't it interesting that in the
meritocracy quantifiable metrics of
success world that we live in now
that we can look at someone that has the
billion pounds but the completely
uninternalized unactualized sense of
self-love
and consider them a success because we
never get an externalized scorecard of
their internal state
yeah and this is like a lot of the work
that i'm sure you do but like what i try
and do with my podcast as well is
i've had you know one of the best things
that ever happened to me
was i was an 18 year old kid 19 20 maybe
19 or 20 probably about 20 years old and
i got to meet the guy i wanted to be
who was imagine that so i can't say his
name
okay but he is a young billionaire so
i got to meet the guy that i wanted to
be when i was that age he was
he was like a couple of years older than
me maybe seven years older than me
he had his nine sports cars right so
he's probably at the time he's probably
29 and i'm 22.
mansion billionaire like young kid
running a business whatever
and i got to meet him and i got to get
to know him
i got to go to his house i got to have
private conversations with him
conversations with him at 5 00 a.m
and i got to go around his house and
look at all of the things that i thought
i wanted from my life it's probably the
most important experience i ever had
i got to go into his louis vuitton room
upstairs and look at all of the louis
vuitton bags he had
nine rooms full of fur coats one trainer
room
which is bigger than my house now and
it's all rainbow like perfectly color
coordinated all the way around the room
and then i got to go downstairs and
speak to the guy for hours
and he became a friend but he's been my
friend for about five or six years
and miserable
miserable and um
probably the last person i'd actually
want to be but on the surface he
he had he was the mousetrap he was
everything i was chasing everything i
thought
i wanted but when i got to go behind the
scenes
the last person on planet earth that i
want to be
deeply miserable and tormented and he
wants to be normal
normal in his own words he said to me
one day he sometimes
goes to supermarkets and puts stuff in
the trolley just to act like he's a
normal person
and and he doesn't actually buy this and
it's just i was just like
[ __ ] you know you've got it all wrong
stop and and this is again part of the
inspiration for the book which is like
i got to see that stuff before i i got
to you know
run down that hedonistic treadmill and
it helped me turn back
you know can you tell us about this
story about the cushions and the chicken
shop and the satisfaction for millions
of pounds i really like them
yeah so i remember this day very vividly
i was actually i didn't write about
write his name in in the book but i was
with my friend anthony logan i think he
might have met anthony we did and
yeah i was next to him yeah so i was
with anthony logan in manchester
this this place called living room and
um i was really really broke at this
point to the point where like i
genuinely on a day-to-day basis didn't
have a pound to feed myself
so i was taking every day at a time
while i was trying to start my business
and i went into this place called living
room which is this like takeaway place
this food place
and i'm sat there and i put my hands i
think i think a pound coin
fell out of my pocket and as i went
reach down to to retrieve it
um more there was so much more money
down the sofa and i just went around all
of the sofas in this
it's like restaurant place and i managed
to retrieve about 13 pounds in total and
i it was like the best day of my life
at the point i was at in my life where i
was living in my side in a above a
chinese takeaway
in a house that was battered and full of
rats finding these pound coins
in that um in that restaurant that day
felt like a gift from god and i absol
an absolute euphoria and i think what i
write about in the book is
that day that moment where i found that
13 quid which meant that i could eat for
maybe the next 10 days or so
was was like 30 times more euphoric than
the day i woke up in that five-star
hotel in manchester
and i looked at my phone and someone
would text me saying oh the company's
now public
and you know you do the mental math
about how much money that means you now
have
um and i just felt total totally numb
and i contrast those two moments in in
my book and this is where i kind of
start to introduce the idea of like you
know bring the stoic philosophy into
play and
and why those and contrast and and why
those moments felt so different the day
that i became
you know a multi-multi-millionaire
versus the day that i found 13 pounds in
a chicken shop
um i were two completely different days
one was euphoria and one was um
anti-climax it's actually when you
expect something to be a certain way
when you expect it to be euphoric and
it's not
it actually becomes a negative which is
interesting
so when you and this is the whole idea
of like i mean this is a general
principle about expectation
and reality like the difference between
what you expect and what you
what you get is your level of
satisfaction and in that moment i was
i've always expected that day where i
became a multi-millionaire to be
confetti in marching bands and euphoria
so when it wasn't
and when it came in below my expectation
it was actually a big negative
yeah until i uh yeah until i did some
mind games
can we sink into that time how do you
get yourself to a place where you can
leave your company this is
as you say a young kid who's never
really had money who's never really had
quantifiable metrics of success a lot of
people would struggle to give up the
good for the great
is is quitting a skill in that way
yeah quitting is definitely a skill and
it's really underrated i think you know
people spend
a ton of time you know words are really
shitty this is one thing that i
i really came to learn in my book is
most of the time which
when we try and answer difficult life
questions we get trapped in words
and like i love you do you love them is
this your passion
we we forget that these are actually
human words that some other
guy made and attached some um
definition to that they felt or they
were trying to describe in their life at
that time and
so it's like crazy as i'm writing this
book i'm
i'm trying to answer these questions and
then like most of the time
the question is answered by questioning
the question
something we just never do we accept
words right
um and to get your point about quitting
one of the things we hear in society
which is really help people back
a set of words is like quitting is for
losers right
you're quitting is seen as this really
really bad thing you don't you just
prevail
but but then they glamorize starting and
starting is
seen as you know this you know amazing
to be admired adventure that people go
on whether it's starting a business or a
hobby or whatever
and the crazy thing is the often
unappreciated but very important
necessary thing you do before you start
something else is you quit something
and quitting and starting go hand in
hand right in all facets of our life
like a monkey
swinging through the jungle in costa
rica they have to let go of the last
branch in order to grab the next
quitting in itself is just as much of a
skill as knowing when and what to start
and in my life quitting visions have
quite literally defined me quitting
school
quitting university quitting my first
company wall park where i'd still be now
trying to make it work
um quitting social chain more recently
and i see quitting as a skill in the
book i talk about this quitting
framework i've devised which will
hopefully give people a bit of a
a a a guard rail or sort of a yeah
a bit of a flow chart um to consider
when they're deciding to quit something
i've quit effortlessly my whole life and
i've never known why
i've never known why quitting has always
been so
easy for me but but when i got time to
write out what my brain is doing
um it started to make very logical sense
i'm very very logical
in the way that i think and quitting has
always been easy so i presumed it was
some kind of logical
flowchart and that's what i uh what's
the process
so if you're thinking about quitting
something whether it's a relationship or
a job or whatever
and i wish i had my book in front of me
because it is quite an extensive oh i do
you're actually leaning we're gonna drop
down by about an inch and a half
get the book out okay and then we've got
the yeah
so um i want to run you through this
because i actually think it's really
important and i've never nobody's ever
given me this before in my life in terms
of like a framework for deciding when to
quit something
and it's also something that i would
love to like i would love to debate with
people because
i was alone in a jungle when i wrote
this and um
here we go so the chapter is called i
quit my job and it's chapter
11 in my book and i've drawn this very
useful little flow chart you can see
here
so the first question is are you
thinking about quitting something right
and you
that's either yes or no if the answer's
no you're why are you looking at the
[ __ ] flow chart
if the answer is yes
go to the next chapter now uh if the
answer is yes
i ask you why are you thinking about
quitting and there's typically two
reasons why people are thinking about
quitting and i
make these words intentionally um
ambiguous so because something sucks or
because it's hard
right and if it sucks that for me means
it's toxic it's
um it's um it's intrinsically
unfulfilling whatever it might be in
your own definition
if it's hard it's because it's a
challenge right you're not qualified to
do it
um it's difficult like running a
marathon you're on the 22nd mile or
whatever
if you think if you're trying to quit
because it's hard is the challenge worth
the potential reward this is kind of the
question i've always asked myself so
in the hardest moments of my business in
which were always in the first years
it was really really hard but the
potential reward in my mind was worth
the hardship so if it's if the answer to
that question is yes don't quit
if you're doing something hard that
isn't worth the potential rewards
quit right let's move to the other side
of the the the um
flowchart say you're thinking about
quitting because it sucks which is
actually where i found myself in with my
company
it started to suck right it wasn't hard
it sucked um
do you believe you could make it not
suck question i asked myself all the
time
do i think i could go and have the
meetings i need to have with the board
and with other people
to make this company for me the company
doesn't suck it's a great company
for me the experience for me and what i
want to have my life not suck
if the answer is yes you then ask
yourself that question again which is is
the effort it would take
to make it not suck that traveling
around the world persuading
worth it yes or no and so if it's if
it's not worth it if you think that you
it would require a year of your life
a million conversations a gazillion
conversations
and it's not actually worth the rewards
to to put that effort in
then you quit if not don't quit do the
work fix it
and you get it right however i got to
the point where i thought that the
effort it was required to make
the experience for me not suck anymore
wasn't actually any worth the rewards
anymore
i was an 18 year old kid that started
you know 20 where i started that
business at 21.
started the business 21 got really
diluted as you get diluted as a young
guy you lose you give up control
you can't take back you know shareholder
control
um the business had got bigger i didn't
have the control i wanted to have over
the the the top level things
and i also owned a small piece of the
company by this point
and so you have those two factors there
where it's it's gonna take a lot of
effort to change it
but the rewards on offer for you as an
entrepreneur aren't actually that great
anymore
so this led me to this part on the flow
chart where
i was thinking about quitting i didn't
believe that anymore that i could make
it not suck
and the effort to make it not suck
wasn't gonna be worth it so
i ended up quitting and this is a
framework you can basically use for
everything i think
it's simplified enough for you to you
know make it work for you and to make
sense for you
and uh and hopefully for the reader as
well
having just come out of social chain how
did you decide what you were going to do
next
it's a really good point it's a really
good point i am i
i went off to the jungle in costa rica
to spend some time alone with my
thoughts which is actually when i
started writing the book
and i think it's chapter 10 or something
in the book where 10 or 11
where i start thinking about that and um
i realize that the tempting thing to do
is just to go and do the same thing
again but there's a number of problems
with that
you know one of the things that i
discuss in the book that makes humans
intrinsically
motivated is challenge and the challenge
of doing the same thing again when
you're the type of person that i am
is um is not very um not very
challenging to say the least right
um and the next thing that played on my
mind was why why i would go and do the
next thing again and it's because
of comfort it's because so i have this
label that's been given to me as by
society and by my past and by my
accomplishments which is
social media ceo and there's this
temptation to
then spend the next 10 years of my life
living out those labels right to think
that's who i am and to
to play the uh follow the implicit
instructions of those labels
and i i dwelled on that and thought that
this is probably why a lot of people get
themselves into these like mid-life
crises where they
they lose their intrinsic joy for their
work and they they
they start to question who they were
because they let society or their past
or their mum
define who they are and then they just
played that role until they got to
41 years old they're working at kpmg and
they're thinking art jumping out the
window
and so i thought the most the most
intrinsically rewarding way i could
probably live my life was to resist my
labels
and to go back to these [ __ ] because
labels as well they're just a bunch of
really unhelpful words that we give
ourselves
to make ourselves make sense so i
thought you know go back to the
fundamentals what am i
right who is who am i i'm a guy with a
bunch of skills that loves
so many things i don't have one singular
passion i have tons of passions i like
music and playing with my dog and my
niece and i like art and i like
video games and fifa and football and
business i didn't like
social media like i'm not a i didn't
come out of the womb
my passion wasn't social media the
social media didn't exist when i came
out of the room so how could that be my
innate passion anyway
but there's principles about that job
and that i did like i liked
working with teams i liked having a big
ambition i liked the challenge i liked
um storytelling and these are things
that can can apply to any industry
so i resisted my labels and over the
last since i've left about nine months i
think it's been now six or nine months
somewhere in that region
um i've just resisted my labels i wrote
a book i i've learned to dj i'm i've got
a big theatrical show that i've sold out
in manchester written and directed by me
the music done by me
i've been working in one of the biggest
biotech companies in the world in the
mental health space
for the last six months a three billion
dollar biotech company i've been working
at huel
which is the fastest growing um black
consumer
there's a fastest growing e-commerce
company internationally in the uk i'm on
the board there
um i'm about to accept another board
role at one of the fastest growing
companies in a completely different
industry in the beauty industry
and why the [ __ ] not i i thought to
myself that like you know this is why
this is how i would behave if i truly
resisted my labels
and i and my inspirations that had the
walls in some of my rooms in this house
elon musk or kanye west i don't love all
of their ideas but the thing i love and
admire most about those individuals was
they didn't let their past or a label
or anything define define them um
elon you know zip to paypal spacex tesla
nira link and kanye started as a
producer and they said you're a producer
you can't rap
and he not only wrapped he put on shows
and clothes and shoes and
choirs and everything and that inspires
me i think that's a free way to live
i think everybody the vast majority 99
of people
don't live freely they live confined by
words
um that you know their mum or dad or
themselves have given them and those
words are restrictive and why be
restrictive i'm gonna die anyway it
doesn't [ __ ] matter
yeah i think um i think one of the
central themes of your book
is to remind people that much of what
we're told by the culture at the moment
will not make them truly happy or
fulfilled
that identifying that is great but how
can
people actually rid themselves of those
internalized values that don't serve
them
i think one of the easiest ways to do it
if i had to just give a
simple way it's like to constantly
question the question um
maybe that's my single greatest
skill or gift i say gift because it's
not
that intentional it seems to be
it just seems to what happen what
happens when someone presents me with
something a good example is my book from
a promo so we're doing my book promotion
today
and i said to my publisher like you know
they said what we do is we get like an
envelope and we put the book in an
envelope and send it out to people
and i was like but this you know that
that's not necessarily a great idea
because we want these influences to pose
so what we'll do is we'll print
100 bills and chris if you get your box
it'll have your face on it it comes with
this like mirror says happy
this big like instagramable box and
we'll send
we won't send a hundred we'll send a
thousand and and they go oh no but
that's not how it's done why would you
do that
well think about it from a psychological
perspective if i see something three
times
in a short period of time if we can get
them all delivered on the same day we
get the world's biggest influences
like this is and but they're gonna but
that's not how it's gonna be done you
and then they're like oh no but you
can't print money that's like illegal
you can't put them
like and that moment there is this that
is a perfect
metaphor for the the slow
the slow almost subtle force
that you'll face many times a day in
your life of life just saying like
stick to the blueprint like and stick to
convention and it's that
little bit of resistance where you've
got to turn and say no we're going to do
it this way
and for me that was at 16 when i decided
that school wasn't going to get me to
where i wanted to go or
university day one where i call my mom
and i say mom listen i'm dropping out of
university and she says
i'm not going to speak to you until you
go back didn't speak to her for two
years those
and subtly it was when i started to
promote the book if you look at
instagram today
we probably had was trying to do the
numbers i was like probably
had 500 000 pounds in free marketing
today alone
sent out a thousand books i reckon i've
been tagged already
you know today what time is it it's like
5 p.m today and most of my friends
haven't got it yet
maybe 500 or 600 times these influences
some of them have 3 million followers
that one moment of resistance where life
in this case my publisher was like
no no no that's not the way it's always
been done and having the conviction to
resist and think in terms of first
principles
um is the most important thing for me
and like i've built the case study now
so you can't tell me otherwise
and a lot of people haven't built the
case studies like you built the case
study for yourself
it's much easier to resist in those
moments
and to rely on your first principles but
uh yeah i thought
so you there's no going back for me now
i can't unsee what i know so
it's thinking in terms of first
principles and very honestly that's just
about questioning the question
every like when you come to promote this
podcast you will do
what you did last time that's what like
most people do and i do the same thing
and like what i do with my team now is
i'm like what is the like one percent
marginal gain what is the like one
new idea based on first principles to
try and get that one percent
and that's a that's a mental philosophy
which is continually like questioning
the question and trying to think of new
ideas even though it requires much more
sort of mental effort
yeah i agree if you do that in your life
you'll go somewhere else if you if
you're able to do that in your life it's
just tough
and it's apparently scary and i say
apparently because in fact
the most scary thing is not doing that
but trying to
try to persuade people of that is
probably an argument i won't win just
like the
jesus bullet mother head analogy i give
like trying to convince you that the
fear
uh the thing that you should fear is not
taking a risk
is a battle i probably won't win well
my tedx talk which i recorded a couple
of weeks ago had a section in this which
is quoted from mutual friend of ours
george mcgill
although i wasn't able to actually
reference him on the slides but i
i quoted him directly from an episode i
did in your old office
upstairs and ollie was filming it and um
it's talking about the fact that i'm
astounded by how many people want to be
spectacular in life
but also want to be normal by being
normal you are
by definition aiming for average
you regress to the mean by doing what
everyone else does by doing what
everyone else does you get what everyone
else has got
normal people get normal results weird
people get weird results
you call it questioning the question i
call it assessing assumptions
like we all have assumptions about the
world about how things should be done
about
the way that we're supposed to release a
book the way that we're supposed to
release a podcast construct a
conversation all of these things
but when you assess your assumptions in
its first principles is now the
sort of buzzword of the last few years
popularized by shane parish and elon
musk
but what i find interesting about what
you just said there
is that it's innate because what a lot
of people want
it maybe it's not in a but it may have
been developed
but that it's something that's built
into your source code
because there are people who struggle to
rebel
and there are people who find rebellion
a little bit easier um
yeah yeah i think it might be somewhat
connected to my
self-belief because i like what you've
just described there where you said
you know everybody wants to be
extraordinary but everyone also wants to
be normal is like
it's like because of risk and reward
like we all we want no risk which is
being normal
you know safety do like stay within the
sheep pen
and then we all want a gazillion pounds
and to live an extraordinary life which
is the reward so like of course we
none of us want risk but we want to
optimize reward and like i think that
maybe
that ability to question you think what
does it take to
think from first principles and to write
your own script
it takes [ __ ] guts for a start
because you are quite literally
writing a new blueprint it's like
walking down you know i used to live in
the woods and i'd walk this path every
single day
to get home and then i look i look up
and i look up the hill
and and i think well i actually live
there so why am i walking this path
which is going to be like a mile down
this way then it's going to cut right
when i theoretically could just cut up
this hill and go straight to my house
and this is like a metaphor for life
again it's like well but this is the
path and
there might be snakes there and there's
not like a carved out
smooth you know way for you to walk and
so what does it take to go up there it
takes a sense of adventure where does
that come from that comes from
probably nurture it takes some
self-belief um it takes
the conviction and the confidence to be
wrong which again probably comes from
self-esteem
right because if i walk up this path and
i get up there and i you know everyone
laughs at me and says well there's a big
fence you [ __ ] up yeah
that takes a certain sense of
self-esteem people don't want to risk
their self-esteem especially when they
have
a weak self-esteem um so
maybe it's more nuts than i i think but
but what i'm saying is now it feels
innate i i i can't
i can't um pretend that i yeah
but and i don't choose it on a daily
basis like the argument with my
publisher it felt like
that was the right thing and it was i
was fighting for what i knew was right
i wasn't thinking i didn't sit back and
think okay let's think first principles
here
and then start like writing out on a
piece of paper that's what i mean by it
feels almost innate now it's so second
nature to me
to question the question and to not
accept questions when they're asked and
the one i talk about in the book i think
there's a chapter on it i say i think
because i'm not sometimes i'm not sure
if it's a chapter or just a section
um which is i know there's a it is a
this chapter it says mum stop asking me
about love
and it's like you come home and your mom
says oh you're dating melanie are you
yeah
are you in love and that moment of like
oh [ __ ] now i have to answer either yes
or no
and i my definition of love has to be
exactly the same as hers
and if it's no then [ __ ] what's wrong
right but and if it's yeah
and then like but if it's yes that means
i'm getting married and the unnecessary
pressure
to like slide into one of these binary
boxes
doesn't help my relationship with my
girlfriend you know what i mean
so why we why do we [ __ ] around with
these questions when they're like really
unhelpful
and and what that's another thing i
uncover in the book which is like how
invalid
questions so many of the questions we
ask ourselves are
you know i think i say in the book as
the example what number
is blue and it's a perfectly reasonable
question because you know what numbers
are and you know what blue is
so what number is blue and it's the same
thing are you in love
have is this your passion i you know
what you are
you know what passion is so are you just
because you can put to like just because
you can ask a question doesn't make it
mean it's valid or worth answering or
worth stressing over all worth
overthinking over
and like 70 of the young kids in my dms
are messaging me because they've tried
they're imprisoned by a question
that society's trying to make them
answer steve i'm
22 and i haven't found my passion
and they're like they're like some of
them are like verging on suicidal
because of these
questions genuinely you look like you
i'm like bro
[ __ ] i don't know what my [ __ ]
passion is either just like stop asking
yourself shitty questions and like
follow your joy and do all the stuff
like unless the stuff you don't like and
that kind of foundational thinking and
not this sort of binary
jump in this box um thinking is is
freeing again
and it lets you live a more yeah
peaceful life
if people shouldn't be trying to find
their passion what's a better
question that they should be asking
themselves
so the problem with the word passion is
it's it's inherently binary it's like
inherently too binary but it also comes
with a definition
that you don't actually know right so
like
a good example would be a good example
like the word like love or passion like
i love my dog
i love marmite i love my girlfriend i
love my mom
lamborghinis i love love love love love
we spray this word around
so like ubiquitously that we don't
actually know what it really means and
it means different things apparently in
different situations
and so if someone comes to and says do
you love jenny
and you think well [ __ ] like oh god
you know i i don't know what you mean
i have to understand your definition of
that to understand if i can fit in the
box you you've just asked me to jump in
um with the passion question i tend to
ask myself in my life it's like
am i enjoying this you can ask yourself
am i happy
do i um do i feel good these are like
more foundational questions which are
subjective
and it doesn't require me to know your
definition of the words and then to fit
into it in a binary way
that's probably what i asked myself in
my life it's like does this feel good
and as it relates to my time at social
change in the end it didn't feel good
anymore
and as i say in my quitting framework i
didn't think i could change it and even
if i could change it i didn't think it
would be worth it so
super easy decision not brave not
courageous
correct brave to stay imagine something
not feeling good you don't think you can
change it
and you do you you think you might be
able to change it but the rewards of
changing it
aren't worth it and you stay that takes
courage
i don't have courage like people say
this when i dropped out of universal oh
you're so brave no no no no
brave would have been staying in a
situation i hated and toughing it out
that's courage
you know what i mean so again this is a
the war of words and how it ruins
people's lives
i get it i think the main thing that i
learned from 1984
reading that is the
volume of your vocabulary and the
accuracy of the words that you use
directly influences the quality of your
thoughts and what you're relating to
here is that
any word is just the nearest
approximation
for a notion that you have in your head
all of the things
all the things the emotions the concepts
that you're trying to convey
you find the nearest possible term
linguistically
apply it to that and then try and get
across something which is subtly
slightly different
we all sharden freud german has some
wonderful words that we don't have
and this is one of the interesting
things about hearing them because you go
oh
that's almost like a thing that i didn't
know it's like a thing that didn't exist
until there was a word for it
and this is exactly yeah exactly what
elon talks about with neurolink as well
and why there
you know he talks about the loss in
communication but also
um how if in terms of like computers and
the bandwidth they have versus like our
vocabulary i think it's the same thing
the most foundational
thing that i the most foundational
vocabulary i have
if you were to call it a vocabulary is
like how i feel
and my sensory experience and then
you're right i try and communicate it
with another person
using these words that we've all agreed
mean something but you've experienced
one thing i've experienced it and we've
said that the word is
love is is that the same thing and
there's a loss in there's loss in
translation there
and that's why i try and take it i try
and take take it back to foundational
things which is like how do you feel
because maybe that's your first language
maybe it's the language which is easiest
to articulate for most people like
we know we have we're quite good at
understanding how we feel
but the societal instagram movie
magazine inspired words like
bae and love and passion these ones are
confusing for me and there's a greater
loss in translation
when they come with all this package and
especially when they're really important
words like
love and passion these are the most
important decisions we make in our life
and we've distilled it to four letters
and we all have to say yes or no
this is a risky [ __ ] game to play and
and that's why i wrote the book
the chapter in my book about like mom
stop asking me about love because like
this is not an interesting
this is a dangerous and risky and
useless question to ask me
talking about instagram how is following
kylie jenner a type of self-harm
yeah this is something that i thought
about a lot in the in the book because
you know i've got a lot of instagram
friends
a lot of girls that are instagram
influencers that i've known for a long
time
and they seem to have a 5x
greater prevalence of mental health
disorders i've always wondered why that
was
then i spoke to johanna hari the you
know the famous author of lost
connections and
the nine real reasons why people are
getting depressed and anxious and it
started to make a bit more sense to me
and then i went and did my own reading
and studying for my book and
a lot of what i was looking at is how
our mind works and how it makes its
decisions and
how it makes these split comparison
oriented oriented decisions
that we needed to make in order to
survive you know 10 000 years ago when a
lion's running at you you think okay
[ __ ] run or when
something happens and you can't over
process or
turn to you know deep logical thought to
find answers you have to make split
decisions
we see it today the studies show that if
you present someone with
three stakes on a menu one's really
expensive one's middle and one's cheap
they'll think the top one's too bougie
the bottom one's the [ __ ] stake and the
middle one's probably the one so they'll
pick the middle one
if in a tv shop they give you three tvs
on a wall
and there's you know the top ones super
expensive the same thing
they'll pick the middle one and even in
more
other ways that you know this thing i
write about in the book where they did a
study they said would you be willing to
drive
um i think it's an hour to save 10
pounds on a 200 pound jacket
or an hour to save 10 pounds on a 10
pound jacket
it's an hour and you're saving 10 pounds
but the way people make that decision is
totally different
they think well i'd rather drive the
hour to save 10 pounds on a 20 pound
jacket
but it's an hour of your time and a 10
pound say with these aren't logical
decisions and the same applies for
instagram
we make very um another example that i'd
like to give is
i remember when i got my first phone my
nokia brick phone and i could play snake
on it i remember feeling like the bee's
knees in school going into school
i had polyphonic ringtones i was the man
my big aerial
if i had that phone today how would i
feel
and i pondered that question you know
like if i if i had that phone today in
a world full of iphones how would i feel
i would feel ashamed
because the value and the phone hasn't
changed the nokia phone is the same
same game same ringtones everything but
the context
in which it exists has changed and that
in the human mind changes
as it does with the menu and the tvs the
perceived value of that thing
and this is what's happening on
instagram is
i know me i look in the mirror every
single day when i look down into this
phone
i'm making very snap comparison oriented
judgments about my own
value my own appearance my own body
based on what i see but what you're
seeing is fake i speak to a cosmetic
surgeon and he says oh my god
this is the best era ever for my
business because girls are coming in
with photos from instagram
he said i've never had more instagram
references ever for surgery in my life
and now they all want to change their
bodies he said the biggest
rise we've seen is girls coming in with
a photo of kylie jenner or the
kardashians
and they want to change the shape of
their body and also the face student ceo
says he sound a gold mine because people
are looking at instagram
the brain does what it does lazy as hell
comparison orientated
it's telling you that because she looks
like that you are a piece of [ __ ]
you can't avoid that that's what i said
there's a chapter called fire your mind
you can't stop that you can't tell me
i'm gonna stop doing comparisons this is
why like half of my quotes i know don't
actually help
because you can't just say stuff like
the jesus analogy you can't just tell
yourself to stop comparing it's a
survival mechanism
but unfortunately in the era we live in
that is
killing your self-esteem it is it's
toxic for your mind
and that's why i say uh stop keeping up
with the kardashians that's one of the
chapters chapter four
there is a statistically significant
increase
in cosmetic surgery called the zoom boom
of lockdown face and it's because of the
amount of people that have been looking
at themselves for
six hours a day plus on video
conferencing calls
and um yeah plastic surgeons have been
reporting that t
john's from up here mr rescho dr esho
was from up here in newcastle originally
um so i've been sort of following his
work for a while as well
one of the things that i thought was
really interesting something on that as
well yeah
like think about the term fat like it
doesn't
sound like a comparison but then remove
everybody from planet earth
and suddenly you're not fat you're the
prettiest
sexiest richest person on earth
you are by definition enough suddenly
just because i removed everybody else
and we don't actually realize that most
of these adjectives or descriptive words
are just comparison based and
i would be the sexiest man alive you
would always kill everyone else you
would also be the young sexiest man
alive
you would also be the fattest man alive
you would also be there and this is
naturally what happens you come from a
hierarchical background ancestrally
and you compare who am i above who am i
below you continue to aim up you
continue to kind of dispose of the
people that are down
um how do you find that creeping in with
yourself that obviously you do this self
work
the same as me we spend a lot of time
doing gratitude journaling and
internal work how do you when you notice
that creeping in that ego that self-talk
that destructive monologue
what do you do it's a good question
so it's a really interesting one because
there's so many contradictions here like
i'm someone and i discuss this in the
book i really
in fact the 20th chapter is kind of
trying to answer the contradiction
between
believing that you're enough whilst also
striving for so much more
always felt like a contradiction i just
couldn't understand and then again i
as i get into the chapter it's actually
just a i'm making a mistake with a bunch
of words
enough sounds like you know this idea
that i wasn't enough
sounds like some kind of like internal
measure of my self-worth that
came from somewhere and the truth is it
did it came from my perception of the
outside world in external validation
i thought that when i was broke i was
less than and so i strived to be more
than or to get to the point where i was
enough and in fact the whole time
i've always been the same there's never
been a change in my intrinsic
inherent value
that was just external um like status
games that i was playing in my mind so i
wanted to get myself to this point where
i knew that i was enough because that
was that's the foundation you need to
chase the right things for the right
reasons
for example my friend who i described
earlier the billionaire friend with all
the clothes in the houses
and the sports cars this is the guy that
doesn't know he's enough yet
so he thinks by getting a room full of
trainers and color coordinating them
that will make him enough
so he started chasing the wrong things
for the wrong reasons the most important
thing for me was getting myself to that
point where i knew that intrinsically no
matter what i did no matter how
successful i become
my inherent value doesn't change um and
then that has become the platform
to be competitive and chase and be
aggressive
at the things that really matter to me
and that's the phase in life where i'm
at now where when i'm chasing something
when i want to be number one at
something or i want to be the best at
something
i'm largely doing it not completely i'm
largely doing it
because the prize at the end of that is
worthwhile intrinsically for me
so i can channel that like ambition and
that competitiveness and that desire to
be number one and to win
but knowing that when i get there or if
i get there because a lot of the time i
set myself goals that i don't think i'll
ever even achieve
um the journey will be intrinsically
rewarding that's been a big thing and as
you say like do i find myself
in moments seeking external validation
or
not thinking i'm enough i'd say yeah but
just like nineteen
ninety-five percent less than i used to
maybe more maybe nineteen
ninety-seven percent or something in
that region
i'm really glad to hear that man like
it's really um
encouraging to know especially coming
from the background in the industry that
you were in
right like you were weaponizing the
platforms that you're now criticizing
your company was built off the back of
that
um and that insight obviously has
enabled you to transform
more effectively personally i've got a
story actually that you told while we
were out at dinner
and this kind of highlights i think what
you're talking about here that you're
prepared to do
things just because you want to win at
them and you're prepared to put effort
in
you were talking about i want to say
that you're at some sort of conference
or maybe a race event
and you and your friends were competing
about who could get the most calories
burned on their apple watch
and you noticed one of your friends on a
sunday night at the end of the week
was in the gym training so you decided
to excuse yourself
and then go and run sprints on a set of
stairs nearby
i was i was at dinner with like philip
green's family
the very notorious billy now i was in
monaco
they'd invited me for dinner first time
i'd met the full family
um yeah very important dinner in this
beautiful beautiful restaurant in monaco
and me and my friends have spent 10
weeks every week competing against each
other six friends
to see you can do the most calories but
then also you can compete individually
at the same time
i'd never lost i never lost i wouldn't
allow myself to lose
so for nine weeks i hadn't lost i'm in
the tenth week i'm at the dinner
it's um 11 o'clock it shuts it the
competition closes at midnight
i look down and i just see don mcgregor
my old business partner who's in the
group
i see him doing a workout at 11
quarter past 11 or something like that
and i'm at this dinner and yeah i have a
personal philosophy where like
i'm not going to voluntarily lose
something else might be the reason i
lose
but it's not going to be it's not going
to be a decision that i make and it is a
decision
so i said just going to i said to the
team and i said i'm just going to excuse
them i'm just going to walk back to the
hotel
i [ __ ] sprint back to the hotel
across the street i'm up in the [ __ ]
the bathroom in the hotel and i put my
phone recording
and i start recording a video for them
in the group and i start doing a hit
workout and i'm screaming at the phone
i'm telling them
i'm saying never try that again you
never try and do me like that again
and i beat them and i never lost i never
lost that competition i've competed
against all of them individually for 10
weeks
and then the whole group collectively
and i wouldn't lose and i don't let
myself lose
because for me it doesn't matter but
it's a it's you're setting a personal
philosophy for yourself every single day
and every decision you make i talk to my
team
about that but i also talk to them
individually like i'm like are you gonna
allow that thing
to be part of your personal philosophy
like the way that you conduct yourself
so
for me in that moment had i let myself
lose like made the decision i was going
to lose then
somewhere in my brain i think that kind
of thinking will then creep into other
areas
of my life that are probably more
important especially as they compound
over time
so i just make the decision that i'm not
going to choose to lose and that was
that story but it's an insight into the
way that i
the way that i think i love that story
man that's why i've remembered it
what do you think stephen 10 years from
now
would tell stephen now
i mean the only way that i could answer
that question is by going back the other
way and saying like what would 28 year
old stephen have told
18 year old stephen so because that's
all i know now right
so that's experience that i can draw
upon and he i would have told 18 year
old stephen
like it's funny because i ask people
this question like really successful
people and they all tend to answer the
same way they all said are you going to
do the same thing are you going to [ __ ]
me up with them
repurposed answer from them like i i
asked ria ferdinand last week i asked
anne middleton and they all say nothing
no noel clark was the one house they all
say nothing because
it might like upset you know the domino
effect of
the thing that led me here but for me it
would have just been
more conviction it would have been like
experiment
even more and and fail faster i think
you know i'm 28 now i think i could have
got to where i am now by probably about
26
25 24 if i just failed fast i had more
conviction
and then the other thing is focus so and
these
it's almost like a bit of a paradox for
me to no it's almost a bit of a
contradiction for me to say to
experiment more but to focus
right but when you choose your
experiments
you double down and you move fast and
harder and aggressively in that
direction
and the worst possible case scenario is
doing
loads of experiments but with with low
focus right so
now in the phase of my life that i'm in
every experiment i do i pick
more selectively and i apply more focus
whether that's in my business my
personal brand my podcast whatever it is
my book
um and that's the point of conviction i
think it will get me there faster it
will allow me to achieve more and it
will uh accelerate my personal
development
and bring the day where i'm my best
version
of myself one step closer although that
that day will never
ever arrive it's always going to keep
moving away man thank you
so much it's been uh it's been long
overdue catch-up
since we were last together thank you
you're killing it and i love
i love what you're what you stand for
it's such a powerful podcast that you
have and i think you're getting the
you're getting the credit that you
deserve for the content you produce and
it's not it doesn't take
long for i think someone that's making
great stuff
there's a bit of a lag on it sometimes
to get the credit they deserve for what
they're producing
and your consistency is inspiring as
well because that's the thing that i
think sort of
comes before great success is just
someone that shows up every day and just
you know follows just does something
that they love so
if i could bet if you were a stock and i
could invest i would invest
thank you man thank you very much my dad
used to say
form is temporary but class is permanent
and uh
i've always i've always held that with
me happy sexy millionaire will be linked
in the show notes below usually
when i talk about the book i like pick
it up like this
but um it's currently at the royal mail
depot for me to go and collect so i'm
gonna do that before it closes yeah what
a bastard
um so i'm gonna go and collect it but
man um congratulations really well done
seeing someone who's young from the uk
swimming in the circles that you do
and personally for me as well utilizing
a team
the way that you do personal branding
team small
focused um it's really inspiring in in
the in the right form of the word
right it's somebody who's grinding
through the operations who's being very
open and transparent about the things
that they do
and about their failures and um long may
it continue dude i think
the uk is lagged behind in this
sort of arena whatever you want to call
it
this sense making insight sort of
entrepreneurial vision world
for far too long and it's our language
right so
if you're part of the if you're part of
the sort of the new age of the british
empire then
so be it i love that you know it's so
true
no you're so you're so you're so right
and that you know at some point you get
the temptation people say oh go to l.a
they try and persuade you to go out
there and you're going out for a month
don't say that i know that you're going
out for a month in a couple of weeks
time
well maybe
no it's good it's really good to see
people from the from the uk like
yourself that are like
creating global platforms because we're
told in the uk to just focus
on people around you know nationally so
it's nice to see you know
you've got killer killer guests coming
on your podcast and that's a testament
to
to you know what you've been able to
build here so well done it's amazing
thank you brother look until next time
man uh we will catch up good luck with
the rest of the book tour everything
will be linked in the show notes below
incl
including steve's fantastic podcast go
and check it out but for now man
thank you thank you thanks
you